he is the all-time postseason RBI leader
in Dodgers history and his on-base
percentage in the postseason is bettered
only in the history of baseball
by Ruth and Gehrig he is none other than
all-star Justin Turner how are you
Justin I'm good then we're good you
you're on with swish here Justin JT with
something man how you doing bro I'm good
I'm doing good man how you feeling after
that late game last night in that early
wake up call this morning what times you
get to sleep last night so you guys are
just going to be going on pure
adrenaline today I imagine yeah it
should be a good one you know when you
play especially twists you know when you
play long games like that losing those
games is extra time especially in the
playoffs so that was a big inning for us
and belly came up with a big hit and
that's a huge momentum swing for us yeah
I think that was one of the big things
that stood out to me last night is
obviously we have we know about belly
struggles in the postseason but for him
to come up last night not only
defensively obviously offensively for
him to get that hit how much of that is
a momentum booster for not only him but
for you guys yeah for him but the whole
team you know I think it's pretty well
documented how you know we haven't been
we haven't gotten going offensively
really in the series so four goes in the
first inning to get the 2 out RBI belly
right there and the extra innings 2 out
RBI you know kind of maybe can get get
the offense going a little bit a little
bit more confidence a little bit more
swag you know bottom line is we need to
start scoring some more runs and know
who has his jersey what happened there
Justin who's got the jersey right now
ripped it right off him in centerfield
I don't know I don't know I was down I
was probably like the
vii guy out there and right right as I
was getting out to him Walker Buehler
went down so I kind of stopped paying
attention to belly and making sure
Bueller could get up and make sure he
was all right so we're gonna need him so
I don't know I don't know who ripped the
Jersey off but you know obviously there
was a lot of excitement and went all the
way out to left field and you know the
boys are pretty pumped now you did you
have a ruler in your hand were you doing
like mass homework or something what was
it our first base coach George Lombard
has a ruler that he keeps with his
defensive positioning charts and stuff
so I've just picked it up and I was
banging on the rails and I was hitting
our trainer Nate lechero yeah I don't
know what was going on there I think we
were all arias at that point
unfortunately running out running out to
the field and stopping to pick up Euler
it snapped in half so well I guess it's
yeah you got to find yourself another
lucky charm for for a game five Justin
Turner here on the Rich Eisen show at
Nick Swisher in studio helping me
interview Justin Turner so I'll get to
the topic that everybody's talking about
about Manny being a dirty player and
what happened at first base last night
was a dirty play where do you stand on
the subject Justin yeah I mean I know he
was running hard down the line and
stepped on the bag and you know I told
him and some other people I think it was
last night or two nights ago when I was
running down a line I think I got Acula
or a little bit so you know he doesn't
hang on the base for a long time
Manny was running through the bag kind
of sweeps him with his left foot I don't
know if he was just mad that you
grounded out or what and didn't pick up
his foot but I don't know him at him and
Aguilar talks about it afterwards and I
guess they moved on with it so as long
as they're fine winters and
anyone else to worry about it do you
think it's anything that might linger
into today and all Justin I have no idea
I mean you know baseball's got a funny
way of trying to police itself and you
know I don't know what's gonna happen
but if they want to put them on bags for
the guys in behind them then that's
their problem I think as now it's like a
fan it's it's so exciting to see kind of
moments like this whether they're good
or whether they're bad because playoff
baseball is so intense
anyways so to see what's going on as a
fan man I love this I love the intensity
of what's going on you know obviously I
played the game as well Aggies a big man
he does stay on the base I don't know if
Manny was frustrated or what but
regardless as a fan all of a sudden now
the intensity is turned up so I love
seeing stuff like that so for you guys
battling up against the Milwaukee
Brewers in such a great playoff series
to be in the spot right now man I mean
you guys have to feel good what did last
night moving on right already you know
really good series that was anticipated
going into it so two two good teams two
teams playing their best baseball -
really good bullpen so this just kind of
amped it up a little bit and and it
seems like it gonna make the reward feel
even better at the end of it what is it
about the Brewers pitching Justin that
makes them better than most because they
have been terrific and really have put
the pressure on the Dodgers bats you
came through in Game two obviously it
took a while for anybody to come through
in a two-out situation last night to win
the game what what is it about this
Brewers pitching that makes him so
effective yeah you know a lot of power
arm still in four seam fastball is up in
the zone and I know you know we had
several guys who had very successful
post seasons last year and throwing that
four seamer with high gloss
to the elephant's own so they're doing a
good job of keeping it up above the up
above the belt at the top of their zone
it's not too high it's kind of flirting
with that borderline strike and we got
to find a way to you know either stay
above it or catch it a little bit
further out front and and put a little
bit more pressure on it yes what is what
is it like can you explain for my
listeners and viewers what it's like to
be in the batter's box with hater coming
down looks like he's thrown from the
first from first base for sure yeah he
just hides the ball so well and you know
from the left side with that true true
spin it's a it's a four seamer that you
know it doesn't it doesn't go that it
almost feels like it's rising on you so
he's a guy that you got to slow him down
you got to try to be on time to be even
get ready a little early and like I said
you got to almost try to swing and miss
above the ball off him so and there's a
few guys and they're both in there like
that I got to ask you man because I love
this ok ok so JT bro you know me man I'm
an on-base guy like I appreciate that
Oh BP in my mind is one of the best
stats that you can have and bro you are
the man you I mean you dominate so I
guess what I want to know or maybe I can
tell the kids that I work with something
that you know that no one else does but
once the post season comes around I know
from experience that postseason pitching
is on another level but it seems like
you have taken your eye and your
approach to that level how do you
compete and do that night in and night
out especially on the on the brightest
stage in the world yeah I think well the
most important part is probably the
preparation going in and watching the
film and studying and knowing how you
know guys attack guys not just you in
particular but different situations guys
on base guys in scoring position and you
know seeing what they're really trying
to do is a big part of it and the other
the other part of it is just kind of
controlling your emotions when you get
up in those situations and not getting
ahead of yourself not thinking about
being the being the man or being the
hero or getting the walk-off hit or
whatever just really stand in the moment
and and trust in your plan and staying
with it
I think it's the biggest key because
once you start thinking about big things
happening next thing you know you're
walking back to the dugout with your
badger yeah I mean it's ghost Gehrig
Ruth Justin is unbelievable what an
amazing career so far bro you have been
absolutely amazing man la is so lucky to
have you bro and we're lucky to be
watching you play man no doubt about
that last one for you Justin comes from
my kids who I took to the game with my
wife in Game three when they saw you
okay now they've seen you my two my two
sons have seen you before my five year
old daughter was her first game she said
I promise you well
look at that beard and then my kids said
when was the last time he caught it so
when was the last time you cut your
beard Justin Turner oh man I got I got
married in December last December that's
the last time that's the last night I
had to trim down it was really short
I've been letting it grow I I mean I've
trimmed it a little bit trimmed around
the mustache and around the neck during
the season but saucy Brown I mean that's
of lettuce down there brother no doubt
about it and if your house is like my
house man come wedding time or anything
important you do what the missus says
ain't no doubt about that brother Justin
thanks for calling it or you're driving
to the ballpark right now you're getting
a dog yeah okay do you know what the
lineup looks like yet I don't they have
two all-star teams my man it really
doesn't matter is not gonna end the way
it starts so okay I'm gonna need
everybody JT brother good luck man hey
man do your thing brother I'll be out
there I'll see you there game five all
right I had in there to grab me you bet
thanks Justin that's adjusted turn out
red turn to the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience